how would it be the next Ralph Lauren if
there's somebody who you wanna be if
there's somebody who you look up to and
think I want to be like him or her then
you have to understand everything that
went into their story everything that
made them who they are you have to
really dig deep and understand the
process that they went through to become
the person and the entrepreneur they are
today because if you just look at the
top level you just look at the surface
stuff you think oh it's easy to copy
what they did you're missing most of the
picture and you're not gonna achieve
success I got a question from one of my
readers on YouTube I love you guys
this one is Fabio who wrote in the say I
want to be the next Ralph Lauren I want
my own clothing brand I want to be like
Ralph Lauren so I thought if I'm getting
started I would be an extra Florin the
first thing I would do is research Ralph
Lauren you want to be like him
understanding what made him a great
entrepreneur look at what look at what
he did to get started I know Ralph
Lauren story I featured him on my
website I'm not even in the fashion
business but I'm a student of
entrepreneurship and part of your
responsibilities as entrepreneurs is to
understand what makes a great
entrepreneur what you can model from
these successful people Ralph Lauren got
started as a tie salesman he was an
InDesign he was a Salesman and he was
working for Brooks Brothers and he
wanted to have them create their own
line of ties and they said no so we work
for our smaller company who allowed them
to not only have him sell their ties but
create his own product and he got known
in the business for selling these really
wide ties the style at the time was
really skinny ties and he said I'm gonna
change this I'm gonna do something
different
and I'm gonna go with really wide ties
and that's how he got known and he built
a huge name for himself and eventually
went on to build brands like polo and I
don't even know if he still sells ties
now but that was his early days so how
did he get started how can you model
that success you want to start in the
fashion business do you have any
experience have you done anything yet
maybe you want to go work for a company
that's in the fashion business just like
Ralph Lauren did
maybe you want to understand how the
business works just like Ralph Lauren
did and then maybe you'll come up with
an idea for a new t-shirt or hoodie or
jeans or whatever it is you're trying to
design and try to make that work maybe
through the company or maybe it's taking
a job at a smaller company where you can
still help them and also promote your
own stuff these are the steps that he
took you want to be Ralph Lauren go
learn about Ralph Lauren have you even
studied what made him successful the
great advantage that you also have as an
entrepreneur now compared to what Ralph
Lauren had to go through is you can
easily test new concepts if I was
getting started in the fashion business
if I want to be the next Ralph Lauren I
wouldn't only research Ralph Lauren also
look at our money a look at Versace a
look at Vera Wang a look at how all
these guys got started but on top of
that I test my designs you have an
incredible opportunity that use social
media right now to test your designs I
don't want you to be the guy who goes
out thinks you have a great idea orders
a thousand hoodies and they just sit
rotting in your apartment in your
basement because that's how most
entrepreneurs who get in the fashion
business that's what happens to them
they end up sinking tons of dollars into
something and it doesn't work out test
your designs if I was getting started I
test right now on Facebook I'd see what
are the stuff that I'm posting that's
getting traction people have commented
and some of my stuff and said I wish
that was a t-shirt that's an indication
that hey meep yard - an idea here you
have a t-shirt design idea create a
t-shirt and put it online get some
feedback see people like it see people
pre-order this thing and then when
you're ordering make it small quantities
I don't care if you're not making a lot
of money on each order and it's so
tempting to say hey if I get a thousand
shirt that's way cheaper per unit yeah
that's true
that's the nature of the business but
it's also overall gonna cost you a lot
of money and it's way better to start
small even though the per unit cost is
higher start off small get some traction
show the people actually want to buy
your stuff and then invest into making
the bigger and blowing it up so that's
your homework you want to be like
somebody you want to be
next Ralph Lauren you want to be the
next Versace you want to be whoever it
is you wanna be the next Bill Gates you
wanna be the next Zuckerberg you want to
be the next Sergey Brin whoever it is
you want to be learn their story
look at how they got started the bigger
the entrepreneur is the easier it is to
find out how they got started and what
made them successful model their
strategies do what they did and put your
own twist on it because you're not going
to be rough floor and you're gonna be
you put your twist on it make it
different make it special make it mean
something to you and then test don't
dump tons of dollars into something
before you see some results test your
designs test your concept test to make
sure it's gonna work use social media
which is free to your advantage
start building a movement get people
excited you want people hoppin when your
new t-shirts actually get produced
that's how I would get started in the
fashion business that's how I would try
to be the next Ralph Lauren if that were
my goal believe those you're watching
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up below it always makes me want to do
more and I'd love to hear we have to
think leave a comment underneath let me
know if you liked it or not you have a
question leave it below I'll make a
video response thank you so much
and I'll see you soon
you